donc nous appellerons cap merci d'avoir fait ça
Jake allons-y maintenant parce que j'ai en quelque
sorte volé cette chose blagues emplois pour se déplacer
dans différentes parties de son canard
spatial un canard spatial est essentiellement un camion ou un
chariot élévateur à bras rétractables pas de visites du
jour au lendemain je  je n'ai pas encore lancé le
moteur de fusion non j'ai été époustouflé la
première fois que je l'ai vu c'était environ 40 tonnes
je suis ce qui est assez impressionnant pour un
rythme défini c'est très amusant
et vous avez détruit un de mes œufs comme
ça non  c'est juste cosmétique
tu peux arranger ça